charles angos petty noces bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france chypriotes grecs
chypriotes turcs réunis donc aujourd'hui
à genève la dernière fois on le disait
que les deux camps s'étaient réunis
state il ya quatre ans alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut attendre aujourd'hui de cette
réunion aujourd'hui c'est une rencontre
informelle à fréthun ou quoique le
secret des jeunes à 21 sur julie qui à
patates et je vis voir s'il ya un
possible terrain d'entente pour des
négociations substantielles par la suite
afin de pouvoir résoudre dure depuis
presque cinquante ans
mais le problème est évidemment résulte
de tuco peuvent pointer la turquie un
premier lieu et le patient chypre en
bois qui est tombé à 60
je rencontre d'aujourd'hui avec
d'immenses informel beaucoup plus se
jouera la rencontre comme une autre et
elle ne peut pas tricher auteurs et puis
les pays car on avec le secrétaire
général et ensuite mais yoann votre
bilatérales h et les familles à un peu
c'est simple appel à la contre 5
c'est le secret la situation est assez
compliqué sur il a pas la mesure les la
partie turque installée la turquie est
avant tout qu'il dirige a fait des facto
tout ce qui se passe on a chip train
souhaite changer et 4 a défini par les
nations-unies pour la solution chypriote
le cadre jusqu'à présent c'étaient les
négociations pour attirer fédération et
peu de répit zonal tels que finir par
les écossais dessus par les résolutions
du conseil de sécurité relatives à
chypre
et et publie maintenant deux mois après
la partie turque dit clairement que
cette solution n'est plus possible et
que le cadre peut pas changer c'est à
dire les négociations doivent être
menées pour la création de deux états à
chypre en arrière pensée bien évidemment
il y à la création de deux états mais eu
la turquie puisse avoir à le dernier
bout sur l'ensemble des lilas
stratégiquement elle veut contrôler la
semblent délaisser sa sanction une
solution à deux états c'est ce vers quoi
on pourrait s'acheminer la réunification
elle est morte et enterrée selon vous
quelles sont les options on parle de
trois options réunification solution à
deux états au statu quo le paseillo moi
moi je n'ai pas de solution à deux états
c'est la partie turque qui demandera sur
des étapes
les chypriotes grecs à mon avis ne doit
pas signer quoi que ce soit qui même à
cette solution de deux états parce que
c'est qu'il faut reconnaître un le fait
accompli par lang réparé puissance
étrangère a mené chypre 1 à une zone en
deux mois à cinq états n'auraient pas le
dernier mot son avenir
mais comme ce sens la vraie solution
c'est la réunification en acceptant
évidemment toutes les pas ne pas la
mettre un que les nations unies ont
défini pour cette solution
c'est à dire une reconnaissance et de
communautés chypriotes des pains chauds
bayrou tout à leur parler d'eux
à la limite ça lorsqu'il vient de
négociations entre les cadres des
nations unies le président de chypre a
agi comme chef et le représentant choisi
par la communauté agi de la même manière
[Musique]
samedi
samedi des centaines de chypriotes grecs
et des chypriotes turcs ont manifesté à
nicosie ils ont appelé à la paix et à la
réunification laquelle elle souhait de
la population à ce que cette
réunification les parties elle et elle
est partagée par une grande partie de la
population des deux camps ou alors ce
n'est pas le cas une grande partie de la
population chypriote grec et turc
soutient cette solution-là la
réunification sous un état fédéral et
communautaire est bien évidemment le
problème c'est que la tuerie de
contrôler l'ensemble est là
donc elle ne veut pas de cette solution
là parce que si les solutions
l'armée turque peut partir il y aura
pendant métrage de la chypre que la
turquie ne pourra pas considérer chypre
comme le scénario de ces zones
d'influencé imaginer la visite de cet
été de douane à chypre-nord même avec
toutes les mesures de sécurité il ya eu
toute l'armature que présentent les
chypriotes turcs ont manifesté aucune
solution fédérale la partie sud jure
graphiquement de lille a expulsé par
l'armée turque par l'avancée de l'armée
turque souhaite également qu'il est
chauffée
là bien évidemment il ya des petits pour
pa ti même temps la partie des points
qui ne souhaite pas cette solution là
mais la grande majorité des chypriotes
sont comme les manifestants de dimanche
dernier qui a souhaité le chypriote
merci beaucoup charalambos petit noz
d'avoir apporté en tout cas votre
éclairage votre point de vue évidemment
de la grèce dans ce conflit
s'ils ont pu dire entre chypriotes grecs
et chypriotes turcs